hey what is up guys mkbhd here and if
there's one thing that's consistent in
tech throughout the years
it's iphone hype in fact i'd say that's
probably the number one question that i
get in real life most often i mean
there's obviously you know what do you
do with the extra tech and what phone
should i get and do you play basketball
but i'd say the number one thing people
really want to know is what do you know
about the next iphone and there's been
plenty of stuff floating around and i've
even prided out a little bit in past
videos but this is all everything in one
place this is everything we know or are
hoping for as far as the next iphone is
concerned so we have the iphone 7 and 7
plus in 2017 right now and we expect a
new iphone announcement in the fall
probably be september again like usual
and this is actually the 10th
anniversary
iphone announcement so this is the 10th
year of a new iphone so we're kind of
expecting something a little bit special
now whether it's called iphone 7s or
iphone 8 or iphone 10 or 10th
anniversary or iphone x there's plenty
of rumors about what that may be we're
kind of expecting possibly one premium
iphone and then two normal new iphones
but whatever that may be we're kind of
slotting this all into the bucket of
new iphones so first of all the design
and this is the thing that most people
get the most excited about because it's
the sort of most refreshing new change
with the phone and through a couple
months of leaked parts and designs
speculation the rumors we have so far
pretty consistent through all the
mockups it's a familiar back with a
vertically oriented camera housing and a
full screen edge to edge display on the
front now on the back that's cool that's
fine pretty much still standard i think
we've all realized at this point that
the actual phone when it comes out tends
to look a lot better than the mock-ups
so the early mock-ups of the vertical
camera looked a little bit odd in the
way it was oriented but now it just
seems like that's probably the way it
will go so that's fine but the rumors
about the display on the front are of
course much more exciting and
interesting first thing is the display
panel type we're actually really
expecting to see an oled display in the
next iphone finally it would be the
first one all the previous iphones have
had lcd displays which are fine but an
oled display has plenty of benefits
including pitch black deep blacks higher
contrast ratios we have awesome displays
from samsung with really high brightness
and you of course have battery benefits
oled displays are great and then of
course also being edge to edge you have
the advantage of fitting a much bigger
display in the same exact body size so
you could see a display as big as 5.8
inches corner to corner in the same body
size as the iphone 7 plus as far as
resolution goes i would love to see quad
hd but knowing apple i kind of expect to
see 1080p again on the larger display
just as far as how thin they tend to
make the phone how small the battery
usually is and what their bias seems to
be so i'd expect 1080p again but then of
course that brings us to the home button
because you of course have to do
something different with the home button
if you want to have an edge-to-edge
display obviously you look at all these
rumors and mock-ups there's no home
button or fingerprint reader on them at
least visibly that's the question so
there's three options here and the
rumors in the past couple months have
been flip-flopping between these three
options even in the past couple days
because no one really knows yet and
apple may even have recently been making
that decision but option one is home
button and fingerprint reader underneath
the display glass
option two is
home button underneath the display glass
fingerprint reader somewhere else on the
back side maybe and option three is home
button underneath the display glass and
no fingerprint reader we'll talk about
all these and i would also say that
these are in the order of what i think
apple would prefer to do but not
necessarily the likelihood of them
happening so option number one of the
home button and fingerprint reader
underneath the display glass would be
awesome that would be a seamless
transition from the familiar iphone
design you know 10 years of predictable
iphone designs to something new and
modern that doesn't lose any
functionality that would be great but
the technology to make this happen
specifically the fingerprint reader
behind the display glass is something
that's brand new and just getting demoed
and showed at this point right now and
knowing apple apple tends to sort of lay
back a little bit and let brand new
technologies get tested and see how the
market responds and then implement
things hopefully better than they have
been and this isn't really something
they have time to do if they want to
implement this fingerprint reader right
now qualcomm is the latest one i've seen
they've done a demo of a fingerprint
reader underneath display glass it can
apparently read through the entire
display it can read through metal it can
work underwater and in all types of
different scenarios it's ideal and it's
awesome but it's a little bit slower
than touch id which is blazing fast
obviously and it doesn't have the
highest success rate and also it's not
mass produced in millions of phones
right now it's still a demo so would be
awesome it's what i want to see happen
it's the ideal scenario but i have my
doubts about it happening so option two
is home button underneath the display
fingerprint reader elsewhere you might
have recalled seeing this on a different
phone this year the galaxy s8 so samsung
got to put the full edge to edge display
in the galaxy s8 and it looks awesome
and i've raved about that in the review
and they also put the pressure sensitive
home button underneath the glass on the
front for all we know they may have
wanted to also do the fingerprint reader
there but didn't have that technology
available to them it was a couple months
ago so they put the fingerprint reader
up here on the back of the phone now
apple pulling that move would obviously
mean now you need to put that
fingerprint reader on the back which
means a different design and a little
bit of a different schematic that we
haven't seen yet doesn't look quite as
good in my opinion but obviously that
has to remain an option if you don't get
that technology and the other way to do
it is option number three if you don't
want an awkward place back fingerprint
reader or if you just can't stand having
it in the middle where it is on the
pixel then you do no fingerprint reader
at all you still have the home button at
the front but then you have other
biometric ways of scanning a face
recognition or iris scanner or some
other way to log into the phone would
kind of suck though because touch id is
already a big part of ios so those are
the three main options for the
fingerprint reader home button combo
again it's not really sure what exactly
is going to happen at this point i kind
of wish i knew you already know what i
want to happen the ideal is the option
number one but that we'll see so those
are the major big hitters but there's a
couple other little things to consider
that are really exciting too number one
to think about is wireless charging no
iphone has ever had wireless charging
couple other phones have which are
really nice and there's been some code
found in ios 11 that's buried some uh
some new sounds you're obviously
familiar with the sound of when you plug
in an iphone to charge that's one sound
there's now a new sound file in ios 11.
and i'll link to the video below so you
can listen to them over and over again
that sounds way more futuristic sounds
like this
[Music]
that that sounds that sound that's got a
wireless charging vibe to me so
obviously wireless charging doesn't work
through metal so if you have wireless
charging on the next iphone that also
confirms that it will not be a fully
metal backed phone it could be partially
metal or it could be no metal at all it
could be
glass like the back of the galaxy s8 but
i think as far as apple's mission of
reducing and removing ports on the new
iphone if you're gonna get rid of that
last port on the bottom wireless
charging has to be a thing obviously the
specs will be new it's usually the most
boring part but also most powerful part
of the new iphone we can probably expect
apple a11 chip three maybe even four
gigs of ram it'll be the fastest iphone
ever obviously and it turns out fast
charging through usb type c is also very
likely which doesn't mean that the next
iphone will be usb type-c it actually
just means that the brick that you plug
into the wall similar to the macbook pro
charger will have usb type-c and in the
box you get a usb-c to lightning cable
to plug it in and then the new cameras
could do a lot more with depth depth
depth sensing depth sensing abilities
this time around which would be helpful
for number one portrait mode can improve
that a lot significantly and also number
two help out with ar kit and all the
augmented reality applications which
have been blowing minds so far and then
colors
there was so much hype and actually
surprisingly a lot of people buying the
red iphone not just because it was
product red and awesome but the fact
that it's a new color iphone we've never
had a red iphone and actually from one
of the shots in my video about this
phone someone made a mock-up of about
six seven more colors of the iphone that
all looked awesome i think it'll be
awesome for a 10th anniversary edition
to pass the torch from the ipod to the
iphone and offer a bunch of colors and
that would be really sweet that i don't
actually expect that to happen at all
that's like the lowest thing on my list
but it'll be pretty sweet so that's
pretty much it for right now a lot of
the rumors you're going to be seeing
over the next couple weeks and months
until that september announcement date
are just going to be flip-flopping back
and forth on a lot of the things we
talked about especially if apple can put
the fingerprint reader under the glass
or not
but let me know what you're most excited
for that's specifically what i want to
see that new design but uh feel free to
share this video with anyone who wants
all the new iphone information in one
place before it comes out as of course
you can expect a video on the phone when
it gets released right here on the
channel so subscribe for that but that's
pretty much it thanks for watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]